this is just how bad things are going  for the 0-3 Lakers and Russell Westbrook  it's tough watch after going oh for 11  and only recording two points Russell  Westbrook said how would you assess your  game tonight  um  [Music]  and then this isn't even a rust problem  this is a Lakers problem but the  shooting has been  honestly impressively bad  and then a personal favorite oh champ  holding up the Whiteboard says contest  without fouling he's got the secret  ingredient the Lakers players need to  get over this home apparently not and  then when the announcers are giving you  advice and upset about your shot  selection  [Applause]  probably not the best